all right so let me introduce introduce
myself my name is machi voiding I'm a
senior software engineer in Bloomberg I
work for the real-time data feeds team
so Bloomberg again is a formal state
technology company selling financial
data in elevate and analytics it's also
a media news company with offices around
the world so let's go over the talk so
first we're gonna do is I'm gonna show
you what is esoteric data I'm going to
show you how data isn't wrapped in bad
formats and coatings or api's will
quickly cover why it's important but
I'll show you how to use pandas to
elegantly compare your data and then
I'll show you how to free your data so
we'll use PI Aero to free our data then
I'll show you why you want to use my
arrow and Apache arrow and then at the
end we'll quickly go over how to use the
Pajero api clang and ginger to free C++
API and I'll show you what that actually
means
so first let's see what is esoteric data
so here's the example of a fixed
protocol message again it's very common
in financial industry it's asking coded
with tag value pairs right and it covers
financial data all sorts of data another
example is this is a CSV file so again
notice we have a row with the column
names separated by the delimiter which
is a comma in this case and the
preceding columns with the values again
another view of the same data so that
this is the JSON view so essentially
each one each row is a Python dictionary
with key values for each column and
finally here is an example of a binary
encoded message so this is a arca data
free trade and typically you would read
these messages by creating a class where
each field in the class corresponds
directly to an offset in the packet and
that's how you would read it and you
would actually read the raw bits
directly from the buffer right so here's
an example and then finally here is a
essentially proprietary class where the
only way to access the data is to the
public interface through the getters of
the class right sometimes it's nested a
lot of legacy systems you just kind of
see this code I mean companies have been
for around
for a long time they have a lot of old
C++ or C code and that's the only way
could actually access and the way to
actually see rows deserialize that's
it's you don't you don't know you don't
care you don't want to know right so to
sum up esoteric data is data that is it
consistently structured has no schema no
human readable output has inconsistent
API interfaces and it's hard to analyze
why is it important it's because that's
how companies make money right so so
you're kind of stuck with it right so we
have to work with this data diff against
old data check change it's up great
precision and your logic so you can't
change the data but you could change the
way you analyze the data but the way you
compare the data the way you visualize
the data so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show you some demos using some
data from the IMF website this is what
it looks like again you know some some
some data which I found it's gonna
straight pretty well so one of the first
things you're gonna have to do with this
kind of data is we're getting your you
know we have a system to generate some
data you make it you make a change
you're gonna have to difficut its old
old data right so one way to do it is if
it's in some sort of ascii format you
could just call the diff command it'll
give you the nice quick diff of all the
rows that have difference the only
problem is you can't really tell where
the difference is you know there's a
difference here there's if it's here the
rest it's kind of hard it's kind of kind
of hard which columns have the
difference it's it's hard to figure out
how many of the columns have a
difference right and again this is kind
of where I'm gonna focus on is kind of
the difference right because again your
own you're making a change to some old
legacy system you want to make sure that
you you know we could you couldn't
figure out if the difference is true
it's good enough it's not a good enough
and you will learn some tools to do that
right so this is kind of the first tool
you're gonna use and it you know it'll
work for some some data sets it won't
work for some others so again another
thing you can do is you could create a
kind of an all command line you know
here you could kind of you know write
the little snippet that's gonna actually
look at the specific columns and tell
you if they
or not you know it works too not as
flexible but I mean that's why some
programmers we know we could do better
all right so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show you how to use pandas for
doing this kind of operation so again
pandas is that data analytics framework
in python most of you probably familiar
with it if not I'm gonna show some
examples so let's start so again so our
standard imports we're gonna Road two
data sets one from the IMF website and
one they have to just I've modified
slightly so this week used to simulate
some differences right again here's the
data so this is a pandas dataframe we
got column so we got the row numbers so
first thing it's doing it if what I'm
gonna do is create a compare function
right so very quickly way we could see
is a top-level view of all of our
differences kind of a percentage why
sorry we could see how many percent like
99 percent 90 it's very close so quickly
see where our differences are on a
column wise matter we could also see
very quickly which columns had
differences which ones didn't and we
could also for every single numeric type
we could find the max difference in that
column right so maybe you know maybe
some differences are acceptable you know
it's bound maybe by threshold you can
make that decision hey this is oh this
is good enough
this is not good enough but again you
have the power to kind of kind of change
the way you do and analyze the
difference using pandas all right so
that that example only works for data
that's aligned all right so what that
means is both both sides have to have
the same row numbers and they have to
have the same size so I'm gonna do is
I'm going to show you how if your data
is not aligned how to line it and then
do the comparison so again for the
layman what you want to do is find some
columns that uniquely identify a row for
a time series would be the date so
something that uniquely identifies the
row right so here's I'm going to show
you some pandas magic so one way of
doing it is you use a pandas merge with
an outer join we we make sure it's
unique and also we actually we're not
gonna do a join on all of the data all
right we're just going to make sure we
join on the data we care about and make
sure we save our row number into the
data frame again some more pandas magic
so here what we want to do is win
we want to get three data sets from our
alignment so we want to get the data
that was aligned the data that's missing
and new data all right so here we have
our align data left only so again this
is data that's missing that was in the
previous data set but not in our new
data set right only it's the converse
right is where we have the data in our
new data set not our old data set and
then here we actually do the comparison
on our align data right and then we do
some more things here so what that
actually gives us a nice summary hey
this is my missing data this is my new
data right and it's not it's not like a
diff it's like this is you know we could
have some more kind of idea about like
you know this is not a diff but it's
actually new data that we introduced
which we have to reconcile right and
then finally what we could do is we
could also look at the diff
friendly fashion so one thing we could
do is provide context right so we could
actually give specific columns you want
to look at and the diff side by side so
we don't the columns that did match we
don't care about but you could also
change this very easily right to
whatever whatever is suitable for the
problem so then you have a nice eye
summary quickly look at the difference
you could spot trends and things like
that
so now what if your data can't be
aligned right what if there's no columns
it's too big it just won't whatever work
so even if you do try it just takes too
long or something that sort so what you
can do is you can you can look at
frequency analysis right so what you do
is this code right here essentially what
it is it creates a series of rows where
every row is every single value inside
your data frame right and what so what
this meeting is it's like minus three
right here the column amount has one
single value of minus three then a zoo
Eila has thirty seven values in the
member but nice thing is you get a
single column you've got a single data
frame with all the columns and all the
values inside your data frames and then
when you would actually do is you would
subtract one from the other the nice
thing about this is if we use the fill
value equals to zero with this
pandas sub function it will actually
make sure even if you have extra values
it'll actually fill in zeros for for us
and then it'll it'll it'll
work right and then then we we get is a
nice summary of all the possible
differences so this value there was a
difference in the amount column right
and here again we have these dates or
different and you know the transaction
value the original arrangement date so
what you get is nice top-level overview
statistical ovary of your difference
right and the next thing is you could
spot trends very easily and for example
you introduced in your date and that's
the only difference you see it might be
still okay alright so and then again you
get a nice overview of all the
differences right so again much better
way of doing it if for your data right
so so let me show you how to free your
data how to make sure we could read any
old data from whatever kind of format
you have the fastest way you could do it
and if pandas be able to read so what
I'm gonna show you is how to use Apache
arrow so Apache arrow is a development
platform for in-memory analytics and
contains a set of technologies that
enable big data system to process and
move data fast it specifies the
standardized language in Tibetan cobbler
memory format for flat and hierarchical
data organized for efficient analytics
operations on modern hardware ok so
that's the definition you could check it
out there I'll show you examples exactly
what that means and why you want to use
it ok
pi r r the python bindings for patchy
arrow in Python and part K is a data
format closely tied to Apache arrow I'm
not gonna go deep too into it you could
check it out but I'll show you examples
you why you want to use okay so let me
start with an example why for for this
right so again we are standard imports
and again so this is essentially how you
would read a CSV file so I just provided
all the possible options you could use
so one thing is you know a
Apache arrow stores its data in a table
so we have the higher up table one thing
to notice it is strongly typed so just
like a data frame so what every Theory
you know column has a type a name we
have you know rows and columns
so again if your data for example looks
like a CSV file but it's not a not a CSV
file what if the delimiter is different
you could always there's a lot of
flexibility in the way you actually read
the data so you can now change it the
delimiter change other things to make
sure you know you can read it by Apache
arrow so you know this will still work
at pandas and I'll show you why you
won't actually use Apache arrow instead
of pandas so let me show you why you
want to use Apache air so again patchy
arrow very similar interface to pandas
so again we have our good old pandas
read CSV takes about 23 milliseconds and
then using the Apache arrow version goes
down to about 8 milliseconds all right
so we didn't actually do anything except
we change this this right here the PA
dot CSV so one thing we also do here is
we do two operations fare first we load
the CSV into a patchy i/o table and then
we convert it to pandas so one thing to
notice is that we use the strings the
cats and the use thread so the read and
then the conversion into pandas is
actually multi-threaded and we also make
tell a patch arrow hey please convert
all our strengths to categories
automatically and I'll show you what
that actually means right so even if our
data was in parquet it'd be even faster
as you can see it's slightly faster
right so that's why again you want to
save your data in parquet because even
though that's by far the fastest way you
could read any data into a panda's data
frame and so so the read again it's not
magic if you'll actually look at the CPU
time it's about closely it's about
eighteen lilies compared to 23 right
because it is actually multi-threaded
when it does the read right so again we
have our JSON example so here it was 144
it goes down to about 15 milliseconds so
here we have tremendous speed up so if
your data looks like a JSON you
definitely want to use this function all
right so I mentioned you know it
converts strings to cat so again
categories
it's a pandas concept what it means is
columns are not stored as strings but
there is such an encoded with a
dictionary where you have an index
inside into the dictionary inside your
column right so here's kind of the
version with just strings it takes about
ten megabytes in memory
then here is the version from batch era
where we converted all cats horses
drinks to cats
1 Meg in memory right so we reduced it
about nine times just by including that
flag so we have the same thing for our
CSV version our JSON version now why do
I do cats matter there's you know you do
have the memory reduction but also on
the speed side so again running our
compare function and it takes about 31
Middle East with strings and about 16
Billie's with using cats so again we do
reduced our processing time by half just
by switching all of our columns to
categories so one thing is you you know
you could always take if you know the
columns up for at a front you could have
you know tell pandas hey
load thesis cats you could always do
this where you take every object and
heard it as convert it to a category but
again it's expensive right it's about 50
million and it's a hassle right and who
needs that so another example I'm gonna
give you so we you know we can cover the
JSON this C's Vedas are pretty kind of
standard way to ways to store data so
let's do something where we have a crazy
rights to parse our data right so this
is just this just a standard CSV parser
so it's actually parse the CSV file so
what we do is we'll you create your your
kind of your to your parse whatever it
is it doesn't really matter right what
I'm trying to show is so what you want
to do is you want to take your weird
data which you have to parse with some
you know crazy logic and you want to
actually save it something better so you
know we could see it's me but we
actually gonna save it to parkette
alright so here's here's the code this
is pretty straightforward we run the the
parser and so you know then what you do
is essentially have her column names our
data is a list of lists with each nested
list is just the values for the columns
and again you know we could store it
inside a data frame it takes 21 lilies
but what we could do is we could
actually convert it stored inside of
Apache arrow alright so here this is
what we do do to wait the way to store
it you actually create a patchy our
array with your Python list of Python
objects and you call froma race and that
creates the tape so again we do the
both operations convert to a table into
a panda's data frame it's slightly
faster again we do get the cats look at
the cat conversion automatically so one
thing is if we didn't actually convert
to pandas from Apache arrow we get about
Emily it'd make 8 milli stright so
actually the conversion into Apache
arrow table is very fast it's much much
faster it's well you know it's almost
three times faster if you just want to
store it in the patchy our table and
again we get the the cats for free using
Apache arrow and one thing why we want
to just first store it inside Apache
arrow table let's say using the regex
right so again using pandas converting
to parque even though even though
underneath this still uses the apache
aero engine you know just writing the
park a file using our table you know
about three times speed improvement and
the reason you want to use parque is it
just takes less space on disk
alright it's about 2 Meg's goes back to
1/4 Meg again we don't you don't lose
any data because Parque is encoded so it
encodes all your strings that's where
you know that's where you get this huge
memory reduction you know it's a win
might as well use it right so one more
other interesting portion of Apache
arrow is it supports hierarchical data
so what that means is so here's a simple
example right where we have two rows
city in population it's double nested
right so we have populations nested in
population is nested again we would read
it into our Apache arrow table here's
our schema so you know petty arrow picks
up does the schema and generates the
generates a schema and the data and
Apache arrow provides a very convenient
flatten function so what that means
it'll actually flatten your nested
structure so you flatten once you get
this find twice you actually get your
all your data structures flat so it's
very convenient if you have you know
nested structures and you want to just
and
and just want to flatten it and then run
through your compare your align the
function you know your frequency any
anything you want really want to do in
pandas now it works because again pandas
doesn't work with hierarchical data this
essentially what it is it's a Python
object so like a dictionary stored as as
a column so that's not going to be too
helpful but with this you couldn't
actually run or any things on it right
so now so I went through kind of the PI
arrow version of it now what if your
data is only c++ right so so now the
penis in c++ or the way where you can't
really equally see out it or so like
that but it's still it's still not good
enough what do you have a lot of this
data right so it's kind of clunky to to
access clunky to use so i'm gonna show
you is how to use Python to create a
converter to park' so what we're going
to do is we're gonna use Python to
parser code using the C index module so
that's part of clang then we're gonna
gender schema and then we're gonna use
ginger template to actually create the
converter and then we're gonna convert
alright so here's our sample data so
this is a nested class we're gonna have
so again no it has to get errs so again
we're gonna focus only on the public
interface because that's for example if
you don't have the source code to the
original class this is the only way you
could access the data that's why it
becomes harder right because now you
don't know what this says you know the
types that it has it would be nice if
something was able to kind of extract
this information there's no schema
associated with this data and our two
messages right so we have message a
message B again message B the thing is
it has the the price this nested class
within it right so so we kind of have to
figure out hey there's there's another
class here with other kind of columns so
in reality what you want to do is we
want to say hey get low get high treat
that as a comment column in our final
dataset again get a and B get prices get
price everything he wants to be
essentially a column each class is
essentially a data frame that we want to
then do our other analysis on so let me
show you how to actually create the
schema
alright so here started with our
standard imports and here we actually
compiled the code
alright so here what we get we compile
messages dot H and what we get we get
the abstract abstract syntax tree
of the C++ code right the nice thing
about it is it's very easy to parse in
Python because it is a Python object and
I'm gonna introduce a single simple
helper function to find a specific node
within the abstract syntax tree and here
what we're gonna do is we're gonna find
all of our class declarations let's
start with message okay very simple rule
so again the interface could be messy
but we wouldn't you put nice thing about
here is you can write the the rule to
find specific ast notes in Python right
then here it's very simple again but you
know you can make it more complex
depending looking at different kind of
parameters about the data again just a
helper function for displaying the the
node and here's our sample message pay
and here's the ast node one thing to
note is you know then you have a bunch
of information do anything you possibly
need about this specific class again it
has children so it has more code within
it right one thing to notice that is pod
flag so P Odie's are plain old data so
this is your answer your floats the
class is not a PG because it has fields
within it so a float our float B is a
pod right but again it's private so we
can't really you know this is Joan Lee
the compiler could see this so then we
look at the function get B and one thing
to notice we also know the result type
and whether the result type is a PID
right so that's going to help us to
generate our scheme and I'm gonna show
you what that actually means in a moment
all right and if we're again we have our
nested class again it's not a pod
because it is another class right so so
we have this information again the PIO d
essentially that's our column that's
that's how we want to break down our c++
automatically so this way we can then we
could save it as a column inside of our
final final data okay so so this
function actually generates the schema
so we're not actually going to break
down the classes we're going to do is
we're going to generate the schema and
then we're going to use that schema to
actually create our converter okay so
one thing we do is here when we do is
for every of our messages for every
class we're interested in we're going to
look for our c++ method that starts with
get very simple you can make this more
complex
so you do have the full Asst so you
could actually look at it more and
figure out you know better ways of kind
of looking at the interface here's the
the display function for GAC she's
getting together and here are the two
functions so the first one we just check
if it's a p OD so the second one it does
two things first it unwinds type def so
we have a type def right what it'll deal
will actually go to whatever whatever
the actual underlying type is and keep
breaking it down but also what it will
do is for any complex class it finds it
will actually try to and generate a
schema for so what it's actually mean so
here we have our message a notice we
have our get a get B with the float and
we know exactly how to generate the code
for this we have the message be and we
also picked up the pricess the nested
class that was actually the class was in
a separate header file but we still
picked it up right just because it was
there and our code was a icy class it
still has data and I still want to you
know continue breaking it down and so
this way we can access it right so then
what we're gonna do is again you know
there's a lot of code here just I'm
gonna post all these slides to to my
github so again we just use a ginger
template to generate the converter let
me just make some points about the
converter so again this is the kind of
converting would have to create so
there's two functions unfortunately you
have to write C++ for right so we have
to write for your Pio deist actual
conversion right so what you do is for
your float on your int you will actually
have to create the schema so this is a
float 32 and in Apache Aero then you
actually have to push the data into the
column same thing for the end you're
gonna have to push the data into the
column so again whatever p OD types you
have you will have to provide these
functions however you want to do right
and then here we have the generated code
alright so we have our convert for
message a we have the two columns so
again we extracted just a and B and
that's what that's the way we're gonna
name our columns right because it was
called get a again you could have more
you know kind of more advanced logic to
do that we have our message B prices in
price here's the ginger template that we
used to generate it and our prices so
again prices gets treated just like a
message because it is another class and
of up or you know C++ knows how to kind
of resolve overloads and that's how it's
gonna keep breaking it down again so
this is you know our getters you're
gonna was our getters and here we use
the display name and name to actually
generate this code the nice thing about
this this little scale right it does it
doesn't care if there's a thousand
messages it doesn't care if there's
thousand getter so just create the code
for you every time right and here's two
more functions you have to implement one
is to create the table and one to
actually write the table to park' one
thing about parquet it is strongly typed
so we have messages with different types
they're gonna have a different schema
right so one way of doing it which I'm
gonna show is to essentially have a file
park a file per message type so and
again this is what this code does so we
have two converters message a and
message B and here's here's the sample
code to drive this right so we have a
main function it goes you know generate
some data and here are the two to park a
file so so one thing about parkade has
extra metadata and schema already inside
the file so harriet again here's the
metadata we have some information about
at the row groups how many rows how many
columns the size by who was created you
also have this schema
alright so right away you know what the
type and the column names are right so
the nice thing is ready we took our C++
code and we put a scheme on top of it
right cuz technically a you know it
classes you plus does have a implied
schema it just it's not exposed right
and this actually exposes it externally
and finally this is kind of what the
data would look like using this code
alright nice nice and compact the nice
thing about this code is you could put
it inside a CI system and actually not
check in the code that gets generated so
this will always pick up changes so this
way you know it's always up to date it
always sees the code as long as the
original code worked and your ginger
templates are fine the coach should
should always you know get generate the
right way get built and be always
up-to-date so so hope hopefully there's
a couple few bits you guys could pick up
that are helpful thank you
very much I'll post the the code to my
github it's that up there yet I'll do it
after the presentation this is what I
used to actually generate all the
numbers and and you know that's my
hardware and know we could ask some
questions if you guys want we have
plenty of time mm-hmm so the question
was should we start with arrow instead
of pandas yes I think so
and I think so if you there's a blog
post that West posted about pandas 2.0 I
didn't know I'm not really familiar
where that's going but I know you know
he is invested in patchy arrow - there
are some there's a project called
Gandiva there's another kind of like a
data frame framework and pan as I can't
remember the title of the top my head
right now I think it's a VIX something
like that which actually uses a patchy
arrow underneath right so so again so so
yes so one thing that I've showed you
right if you actually just instead of
leading like your CSV file or your JSON
if useful patch arrow you automatically
it's gonna be tremendous speed it
increases right and then you actually
you know it doesn't support a lot of
things it does convert easily into
pandas but you couldn't you know if you
don't actually if you just want to
convert some data from something it's
much better just to use it in Apache
arrow and you always have the ability to
convert it to a panda's data frame after
all right so yes exactly
yes exactly so it doesn't have that
analytics any of that analytics at this
point right but it is a better way to
represent you know
yeah the way like numpy I think you
really you know people look that numpy
and they say hey let's make it better so
this way it actually works across
everything right so this is a Apache
technology right so what it is it works
with like Hadoop and spark and things
like that that's the kind of the point
where you would create your data once
and you could move it around these
systems without actually you have to
deserialize and we see lies that they
didn't like encode it would be just the
way it is actually laid out in memory so
yes all sorts of yeah every single
language yes mmhmm yeah I don't have a
list but yeah see at all the major
language is it again it is you know it
is parque it's very tightly note i to
park a park a is the you know the fact
is standard in no big data so
exactly yes so the way you do it is so
you would have to essentially use shared
memory it's called do you have a you
know you could do yourself what they
deal was you could do it over Kafka
however what they do is it's called
plasma so it's put it's part of part of
the project where you would actually do
whatever shared memory so you would
actually put your arrow table directly
into shared memory and something else
could just attach attach the shared
memory and just read it directly it
wouldn't have to actually change the
data right so you know yeah you wouldn't
be able to kind of move it around
between you know that's the only way you
have to do some sort of IPC between to
kind of you know like a Java and C++
because there's you know separate
processes but on the shared memory side
what since in shared memory you wouldn't
have to change it at all you know
because it's but it's like a
specification of how to layout memory so
this way any any system can read it any
other questions
I don't know honestly III really use it
you know I use it for analysis
it seems very stable we're actually
gonna have some projects that will go
into production with this you know I
feel to put it I see I see Amy we could
talk yeah so I use it it helped out
because again I don't know you know in
Bloomberg we have a lot of this code
which is only in C++ right and then just
you know you'd have to look at a lot of
differences we have to figure out
anything and it's just so much easier
just to do it convert it you know that
takes time unfortunately but it's still
better to actually have you know you
could just do it in panda it's much much
better way of than doing anything else
you know and yes people actually do that
the ark example I've seen you know I
write work people do that's the first
thing to jump on so you know no no it
doesn't but you one thing you can do I'm
not sure if it could read from like HDFS
cuz it is not it's not it's not it's not
sequel right so like as long as it's
bits I know I know one thing you can do
on the C++ side you can there's a like a
like a file stream right so you could
actually see but let's say into like a
Kafka message and then like broadcast
broadcast that right so it's old so the
sequel side that would be something on
top of a batch era that would actually
look into the data you know so it
doesn't support that at the moment right
yes any you know it doesn't support it
doesn't flatten lists which is
unfortunate but and yes so you could
actually read a JSON with like nested
structures into an Apache arrow table
and if there's no list you can actually
just keep saying flat and flying flatten
it'll just flatten everything that's
pretty convenient if you have something
that kind of data so
questions comments all right well thank
you guys so again
[Applause]